oh là là là là ce n'est pas joli joli
thierry vous nous annoncez du sport et
vous nous diffuser des cochonneries
vous êtes un gros malone être guéri je
l'avais pas vu ce truc là je viens de
découvrir comme bout j'avais pas vu le
montage c'est vrai ce mensonge juan
professeurs non non c'est vrai
maintenant je vais vraiment pas vu puis
là je vais vous montrer un truc qui va
vous il va vous plaire c'est plus
intello c'est une interview de jacques
derrida
enfin vous allez voir comment vous
pensez aujourd'hui le rapport entre
philosophie littérature et à ce que
finalement les parcours qui ont été les
vôtres et dans la philosophie et dans la
littérature ne vous conduisent pas à
penser que l'écriture littéraire
finalement résout des problèmes que la
philosophie pose sans être capable de
les résoudre
j'essaie de rassembler là c'est tout
simple les et des références
essentielles littéraire qui sont les
vôtres et quand on fait cette
bibliothèque
on se dit c'est vraiment quelque chose
en commun et c'est sur quelque chose en
commun que tu voudrais vous entendre
artaud bataille
joyce blanchot c'est pas le scellant au
fond qu'est ce qui rassemble ces
écrivains qu'est-ce qu'il fait leur
pourquoi sentir dans votre panthéon
c'est certainement pas un panthéon
d'abord 7,7 s'est ouvert ensuite
j'hésite à répondre à cette question là
parce que si je répondais je dirais
voilà c'est en ont quelque chose en
commun et ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
qu'ils ont en commun
thierry très bonne surprise parce que ce
document est très intellectuel et
pourtant le la courbe n'a pas cessé de
monter comme quoi contrairement à une
idée reçue bien la culture ça peut aussi
payer sur le service public c'est
formidable c'est pas fini professeurs et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux